okay our next speakers for honest
tana she's a geographer
his work for a variety of international
organizations NGOs government agencies
she was International Water Management
Institute fellow at the University of
Minnesota and she's a co-editor book the
right to water politics governance and
social struggles hi Thanks to everyone
who's still around as I see a lot of
students coming in and out so I'm going
to change and shift everyone's gaze a
bit we've been talking a lot about the
science and the modeling and
international perspectives i'm going to
really try to humanize it I was asked to
talk about well what do we mean by the
social impacts of climate change and
changing water patterns so I'm going to
really do a micro scale analysis but
before I start to do that let me just
put it into some background and context
so what you know how did I arrived at
the analysis that I mean representing to
you so we discussed last night and
pretty much throughout this morning and
this afternoon that water issues climate
change and all of the related things are
complex rights a complex issues require
complex analysis and I think what's
really important and this is particular
to students or is still around that
these kinds of multidisciplinary
conversations are important an
interdisciplinary understanding is
really required for us to address these
very complex interdisciplinary questions
so my perspective is informed by my own
interdisciplinary training trajectory
and experience so the joke i was having
last night was well there's a lot of
geologists here I'm a geologist to with
an ex geologist who happened to have
worked at Princeton and she have to yell
but then I became a geographer because I
realized I loved the earth but I like
people on the earth more and then I went
off and worked for the UN for a while
and realized okay this is how policy
works or doesn't and then I decided to
become an academic because this is what
I get to do all of the things I want all
of the time and I have that academic
freedom to do so so what's driving this
interest for me is that the compelling
human component of what what I saw what
I witness what I research
and so for nuance social analysis we
really do need to have a more
comprehensive appreciation of the
complexities of this world so I think
that's where for me the real fascination
lies so we can have all the science and
technology and all the models but social
processes and the challenges are
effectively where the rubber meets the
road we can theorize hypothesize have
models have plans projections hypotheses
but things kind of fall apart right when
it hits the ground and people get
involved people are messy we're very
messy creatures adding to that you know
this is all about climate change and
then we start to understand that well
when we think about water as a social
process not just as a thing but how
water effects so we organized as human
beings it really complete complicates
issues even further so we see that water
seeps into everything right and it's a
social issue it's a political issue
economic ecological technological
scientific and so on and so forth I
they're not spiritual but I should have
is it's a cultural and spiritual issue
as well so for me water is the lens
through which I look at these complex
human environment interactions and
relations and that's the kind of human
narrative that I find very compelling
that I'll try to share with you today so
in on top of this we have a messy
society we have messy water problems and
add the additional layer of complexity
from climate change this complicates
what we know and what we don't know and
it disrupts what we think we know and
what is even a noble at this point right
so again it is gloomy and do me but not
entirely because we can draw upon
existing knowledge and research to
inform us to help us hypothesize better
for to help us project better to help us
think about well what are the social
implications of what might happen or may
not right so the focus of my talk today
is going to be the importance of gender
and class analysis in the climate water
nexus in a rapidly changing world so I
will do social analysis but I'm going to
take it apart a little bit more and say
well what is social who are we as humans
right we're intersected by all these
different axes of social difference so
give you some case studies from my own
research
and hopefully you will be able to then
you know ground a lot of different sets
of disparate narratives in one place so
first let me talk about the importance
of water well we know water is life
without it we can't survive we it's a
non substitutable resource we can't
drink oil unfortunately that makes water
in a very important public or common
good and such as a couple of quotes for
you that thousands have lived without
love but not without water that was from
Auden then we had Ben Franklin's code
which I think was quoted last night when
the well is dry we learned the worth of
water and then Mark Twain said whiskeys
for drinkin and water stir fightin over
but lastly my favorite one is from the
United Nations from just a couple years
ago which is the right to safe and clean
drinking water and sanitation is a human
right that is essential for the fulfil
the full enjoyment of life and all other
human rights right so this again is
effectively on what Peter alluded to it
is almost legally binding it's still
controversial how you do it but we've
come to realize that water is one of
those things that as human earthling
beings we really can't look at that so
bringing it back up to okay we know it
importance of water but what do we think
about in terms of water governance and
climate change and as some of these
issues were highlighted earlier
throughout the day right we've talked
about the increased frequency intensity
and magnitude of weather events and
ecological changes I won't go into all
of that because I think all of our
science colleagues have done that quite
well throughout the day so we're seeing
that greater variability and greater
uncertainty so already in a complex
messy social world we have these added
uncertainties that are being you know
compounding existing and potential
problems however these are very place in
context specific so all the really
really cool graphics and images that you
saw with all the nice colors showed you
how it was different right sea level
doesn't change everywhere equally
hurricanes and cyclones don't appear in
the same place in the same way so add to
that the fact that there are social
differences there's ecological
differences and there's spatial
differences and how
do things in even very small spatial
scales so there are two interlinked
aspects regarding water that will have
significant social implications both
directly and indirectly I'll spell them
out then I'll go into each one of them a
bit in greater detail so the too much
water problem right there's too much
water where you don't want it so
basically worsening of water-related
hazards and disasters so there's
cyclones hurricane storm surges floods
riverbank erosion andand asian sea level
rise and so much so it's the problematic
wicked water that people which didn't
happen then compound with that is too
little water where you wish you had more
safe water so increasing water shortages
or availability and the all-encompassing
access to water crisis though we have
talked about briefly but I'll go into
more detail so this could be from water
contamination you know whether it's
encroachment of salinity or some other
pollutant reduction in groundwater
supplies droughts changes in rainfall
patterns then the accessibility issues
water governor's krytus crises in cities
so on and so forth so you've got the too
much water and the too little water no
one's fully happy with you know the
perfect type of water governance that we
wish we had we don't really have that
anymore so when we think about the
social aspects of these water crises and
again the images at the bottom are
supposed to give away what I'm going to
say so test yourself so in the too much
water issue so water-related hazards
have gendered and classed impacts so
nearly three times more women compared
to men died in the 2004 boxing day
tsunami in South and Southeast Asia so
you have entire villages where there
were no mothers you have single fathers
raising children because the mortality
and morbidity rates amongst women were
incredibly high especially in places
like Banda Aceh in Sri Lanka so when we
talk about vulnerable communities we
need to recognize that yes it's a
community but no communities are
homogeneous right so they're
differentiated by gender and often
further differentiated by class and race
and age so even if we think about an
American example of Hurricane Katrina
you some more women of color poor black
women
the Lower Ninth Ward who really really
suffered compared to other women and
other categories then if you look at the
two little water problem right water
shortages and water crises have gendered
implications to who do you think is
fetching the water and majority of the
world think about your
great-great-great-grandmother think
about Little House on the Prairie who's
going to the well to hold the bucket
it's usually the women in almost every
culture until we started to have tap
water which is not very prevalent
everywhere so women are largely
responsible for managing water in the
home and this ends there for drinking
water crisis affects women and girls
just disproportionately girls are often
asked to stay at home not go to school
to help deal with the amount of water
that's required for drinking and cooking
and bathing purposes in the home and
then we see also health effects from the
lack of water or exposure to
contaminated water which affects women's
lives and live you had opportunities in
many parts of the global south and what
I mean by the global South I mean most
of South America Africa and Asia right
the so-called third world controversial
definitions please look them up if
you're really interested in what the
difference is in the terminology but
basically in the so-called third-world
or developing world we're seeing that
amongst marginalized communities the
first group of people to bear the brunt
of these water related crises whether
it's too much water or too little water
are the women and usually the girls so
for all the hydrologists out there these
hydrological changes have significant
social implications across social groups
and communities and for me that's what
compelled me to still be interested in
hydrology and hydrogeology but look at
the human element further so what do I
mean by doing social analysis and why do
I think it's important for all of us
whether we're scientists policymakers
politicians planners and so on because
you know what we live on earth with
people and people are messy as I said
before we can have very bad plans that
are derived out of very weak social
analysis and I think the litany of very
bad development planning that's hot
in the last 60 years is testament to bad
planning which led to bad policy which
then had unforeseen and forcing outcome
forcing outcomes dams being one of them
great and then we realize the huge
sociological and ecological impacts of
dams so if we look at first let's look
at the disasters on an ecological shocks
so to do a social analysis in any
situation of disasters we've been
looking at the differential coping
mechanisms and vulnerabilities how do
different groups of people cope who's
responding and why are they responding
that way so for instance I give you an
example here again I'm just going to go
through this very quickly but I'm happy
to elaborate later so why did so many
mothers die in Sri Lanka and Southeast
Asia simple ability to swim or rather
inability to swim so women often were
holding on to children not being able to
climb up on the trees to survive or
never taught to swim so this does not
mean go out and teach women just to swim
right there other issues involved but
yes some of those basic skills were
there but often women were not leaving
the home they're taking care of the
elderly they're looking after the
livestock and they're hoping that the
storm wouldn't come and wipe them away
but unfortunately that explains some of
those gender disparities we see in
mortality and morbidity rates I'm a
second point would be you know the
differential abilities to respond to an
adult to adapt to those kinds of changes
that are happening we're seeing those
kinds of ecological shocks increasingly
I mean one of the gendered impacts is
the distress selling often of women's
assets so when a family has lost
everything to drought or to flood or you
know inundation or erosion what gets
sold may be the one little gold jewelry
a chain that the mother had as a wedding
gift maybe some utensils or pots and
pans those are distressed sales which
then have a serious impact on women in
many communities because that was
probably their last asset but that's
often the first thing to go in order for
the family to survive so they can issue
that we have to look at if you're going
to do good social analysis in this kind
of complex climate change water stress
world is looking at those issues of
access and can
and management of resources so who's
doing what with what resource and why so
this gender division of labor is very
common throughout the world men irrigate
women fetch domestic water or men will
go off as fishermen into the high seas
and oops you're right too many buttons
somebody's about this morning so there
is that kind of gender division of labor
and and again in parenthesis what I have
here is triple burden that a lot of
social scientists will say that women
end up taking on the first primary
burden of taking care of the home then
often they're employed in some sort of
wage labor whether at a job or in their
local community so that's a double
burden then looking after the whole
community becomes a triple burden right
to see if other families are taken care
of if food needs to be provided so you
see this kind of taking on of increasing
types of labor during times of crisis or
times of shortage and then we also have
to then recognize that gender doesn't
exist just by itself it's intersected
with other axis of social difference and
what I mean by class race and age so
Queen Victoria is a white woman but a
poor woman in rural Appalachia is a poor
white woman who is not the same as Queen
Victoria but what do they have in common
they have their white and their women
but they're not of the same class this
is what basic intersectionality analysis
means we need to do this very well in
each community otherwise we start to
homogenize communities which is doing a
disservice a third issue is looking at
rights responsibilities and rewards and
this is a bit tricky because you need to
kind of understand what's going on
locally and the dynamics of different
regions and different societies to
really understand how to make sense of
the complexities involved so for
instance if you look at legal and infirm
or informal rewards and responsibilities
or rights so what we're seeing is
there's a systemic inheritance bias so
often men will inherit land but women
won't and that disadvantages them when
different kinds of crises affect them or
if there's a less a government
redistribution effort and they will look
at who is
the title holder of the household so we
see all sorts of complexities I'm just
throwing out some a couple of examples
just to set the context and how do we do
this kind of analysis and how do we make
sense of this so we have to look at both
the legal formal and in the informal the
unset but what's the customary practices
and then we need to look at the
differential capacities and capabilities
and what I mean by this is how do
different people deal with what comes
afterwards whether it's too much water
too little water or none at all right
you've been completely displaced how do
people negotiate their right to a
livelihood how do they make sense of how
to become economically engaged or
socially not so marginalized so many
many different ways at different
households and different members of a
household will respond and react to
what's what's available to them I'm a
fourth effect and I think this is quite
important are paying attention to social
norms and perceptions and this is where
the word patriarchy comes in and many of
you may be familiar with that but
patriarchy is is as old as cavemen it's
the rule that dominates most of social
organization it's a rule of well the man
should have to say a woman's place is in
the home we've seen some of that change
in the US but not so much why we're
still seeing people talk about leaning
in well how do you balance children and
you know careers and all of that other
conversations in the u.s. so we need to
understand that how in the developing
world notions of appropriate feminine
behavior and appropriate masculine
behavior are conditioned by local
practices of patriarchy often religion
is used to prop up all kinds of nonsense
and then you have the dutiful daughter
and dutiful wife syndrome well a good
wife wouldn't do that or a good daughter
does this right and don't tell me
doesn't exist in the West all of you who
watch Downton Abbey know very well how
fathers worry about marrying off their
daughters right so the good daughter is
the one that finds herself husband so we
see all kinds of social norms and
perceptions that influence or constrain
what can and cannot be done and that's
why I have that second sub bullet that
says appropriate nurse possibilities and
constraints because they exist in every
society
it's some issues are more pointed than
others but we need to pay attention to
these issues to make sense of why people
respond or adapt the way they do or the
way they don't a fifth issue is poverty
and the livelihood resources and
constraints that people who may have or
the opportunities they may have so there
could be constraints that are both again
formal and informal so maybe you're in a
community whether it's an Asia or Africa
or Latin America we need to understand
how are people making a living how are
what do they aspire to are they living
with cash transactions or maybe in kind
or the chronically on credit and debt so
the multiple ways that everybody makes
sense of their livelihood and their
household economies and then we to
understand the multidimensionality and
multi causality of livelihood choices so
maybe you do raise goats and sheep on
your farm but then maybe you also need
some sweaters maybe you have a son who
participates in a migratory job process
and sends back remittances right so
there's every household diversifies its
strategies of survival so we need to pay
attention to what's going on so that we
can make sense of what people are likely
to choose to do after the or wit along
with these changes an important issue
with this is what we're seeing is
globally a feminization of poverty we're
seeing an increasing rise in
female-headed households where the men
have either left maybe they've migrated
somewhere else to work or they've gone
off to war or they've died but we're
seeing increasing single headed
households often led by mothers and that
puts an enormous strain on that entire
family a lot of point in social analysis
and climate change research is to
recognize that there's some really
problematic literature out there that
sees women as victims and as
simultaneously as valorized agents so
yes women are often the victims but they
don't always have the agency or the
willpower or the rather the political
power and the resources to do the things
that sometimes they're asked to do in
very different projects so we have these
problematic stereotypes
really really careful about the
stereotypes right because gender
implications and realities vary by
context you know you may have a
matriarchal society or you may have a
society that places different importance
to you the elderly the mother-in-law the
grandmother then it does to the younger
daughter-in-law right so there's all
kinds of changes and then you also need
to pay attention to those issues of
gendered exclusions and marginalization
and silencing in the very way we you
know collect data on in research and in
planning and in implementation because
the biggest problem I've come up against
is um yeah sure we interviewed a woman
done who did you talk to the clan elders
wife and she spoke for all the poor
women everywhere in that whole region
not really sure a clan elders wife has
the same experience of fetching water at
four miles she probably has somebody
else do that for her so we need to
understand that you know that
intersectionality issued that we need to
talk to ranges and groups of people to
understand those complexities and then
at the same time look at the huge bodies
of literature in the social sciences and
in policy to not romanticize these terms
of community and participation
empowerment you have no idea how
problematically these are bandied around
especially in climate change literature
that and the community will participate
and people will be empowered to be
resilient wow that's a mouthful of
buzzwords what does that mean but we see
that all the time so again I'm trying to
problematize and ask us to do better
jobs so when I say well what does
gendering climate change mean right and
here again a couple of photos and the
first one is from the ball EcoP in 2007
and the bottom one is a strange picture
used at the UN that says it's up to you
n now or maybe it's up to you now
however you want to interpret it so in
the ball Ethiopia 2007 it was the first
time where you had a lot of scholars and
practitioners and activists who actually
said we can't have climate justice
without gender justice that we can't
about adaptation and climate resiliency
unless we start to pay attention to the
issue of gender and I would say and race
in class so what they argued is that we
need to have better gender disaggregated
data and focus that's really been
lacking international climate change
debates and in national discourses so
for instance the Napa is a national
adaptation plan of action that every
country is supposed to draft in many
countries have you do see a complete
exam you know no attention to those
kinds of social complexities that end up
confounding whatever they implement a
second aspect of gender and climate
change means looking at those
implications that I just talked about
the rates at which women and girls are
disproportionately at risk or vulnerable
or made vulnerable or impacted compared
to men and boys in their own society so
we need to understand those processes as
well as understand the data and then
again do very nuanced intersectional
analysis that makes sense in that
context so maybe in a context of a
similar ethnicity group race analysis is
not important but class analysis is and
Katrina race analysis was very relevant
and important right but it may not be in
every context so we need to understand
how these other social axes of
difference become relevant become
poignant right become important in you
know for this messy social world we live
in and then we need to really understand
and this is what a lot of the more
recent literature has been highlighting
that the multiple knock-on effects from
these socio ecological changes so
whether it's infrastructural damage or
livelihood loss or you know crop
failures or out migration and all of
these issues that are driven by climate
change water stress you know again play
out in each household energy community
and in very gendered ways and then it
also means paying attention to those
very unequal power relations within
society paying attention to who's poor
who's not how is poverty playing out is
it institutional is it driven by
different you know
historical legacies of different groups
not getting along together is it a
certain form of feudal exploitation
there are lots of different ways that we
need to do better social analysis to be
able to implement better climate change
policies so we need to then understand
how those climate change disruptions or
impacts right add another variable to an
already complex messy variable situation
and then this last point in what does
gender and climate change mean before I
go into my two empirical examples is
well you know we're seeing a real flurry
of adaptation projects and adaptation
funding well what does that mean we need
to do a better job of asking and
critically investigate well who's doing
the adapting where they're doing it how
are they doing it why and with what
means whose laws are they following
whose guidelines and is it locally
socially politically culturally collage
Utley really relevant because maybe it's
not what's relevant you know 10,000
miles away may not be relevant here so
we need to basically understand that
adaptation is not just technical or
infrastructure but it's a very much a
social process we can build the you know
the Dutch dikes or the embankment sin
the sea walls but how people respond to
them how they look after them how they
then adapt their lifestyles and
livelihoods it's a very social process
and then we need to understand the
non-linearity and complexities and I
think a lot of our good scientist
colleagues pointed that out to us all
day but we need to understand the
non-linearity and complexities in the
social systems not just in the climate
systems and then recognize the
variations across sites and scales and
what I mean by this is there's great
variation in fairly short physical
distances because agroecology could be
very different there right and then also
across scales what may make sense at a
micro scale may not make sense at a meso
scale or a regional scale so we need to
have that kind of flexible planning that
adaptive planning process and then of
course again to bring it down to the
human level we need to pay attention to
the local politics or local power
relations and the adaptation
possibilities so if you know hydroponics
and caged fish aquaculture makes sense
great but what is nobody there is used
to caged fish aquaculture nobody wants
to do it it's not going to really make a
lot of sense you may implement it go
away you know use up a lot of donor
money and then realize that it didn't
really take hold so it wasn't really a
socially sustainable project to begin
with and again to drive home a point
that I've already repeated many times
pay attention to those gender norms
regimes and practices that influence the
very adaptation projects that are being
implemented in the name of the poor
often in the name of climate change
resiliency and then we need to pay
attention to that adaptation can
actually exacerbate right and change an
ultra vulnerabilities I think an example
was given that if New York built a huge
sea wall Connecticut chores would get
flooded right so we need to understand
how we can externalize externalize those
kinds of impacts or rather how it can
also come back in a indirect way to
affect people so i'm going to give two
quick empirical examples from my
research and again i'm going to go
fairly quickly in the interest of time
but them but i'm happy to elaborate so
again they're going back to the first
two points I made you know too much
water too little water alright so the
first one's called climate change
impacts and looking at gender and class
what does it mean so all the stuff that
I've said that may sound very vague and
obtuse I'm going to ground it to an
example and then the second one would be
about adaptation strategies and how does
gender and class become relevant there
so the first one is looking at tropical
cyclone storm surges and their gendered
impacts so we've learned that tropical
cyclones ferry across different phase
and oceans and estuaries so one of the
places in the world where very very
violent cyclones happen is in the Bay of
Bengal part of the Indian Ocean and as
you can see in the bottom map on the
bottom left historically they have a
tendency to come up the Indian Ocean and
swing right that's because this is a 90
degree angle shoreline as a way to kind
of focus and channel both the cyclonic
storm and then also the
of the sea storm surge and I've just
given a couple of storm tracks now
what's interesting a point that was made
earlier that how these kinds of
disruptive weather-related events can
lead to political change night this one
led to Bangladesh going to war with
Pakistan and becoming independent 1971
it was a colony of Pakistan it was
called East Pakistan until 1971 the
cyclone in 1970 where the mothership aka
current day pakistan did not pay
attention really led to that kind of
uprising so yes disasters do bring about
change this one 1991 150,000 people died
it came without warning it was a huge
storm surge and it just flattened and
went up there stirring up the rivers and
don't forget they said this is one of
the most active Delta's in the world
you've got the Ganges River coming from
the Himalayas there you've got the
Brahmaputra coming through the Himalayas
over there you've got two massive rivers
with huge sediment loads and a huge
subsided straight and the peak at
different times and you've got this
nasty water coming up and they have
nowhere to go this one in 2007 not such
a huge human casualty but more property
damage so therein lies the paradox of
what paradox of what development means
right so in the West you don't have such
human casualties during the global South
you usually have huge human casualties
until people start to have better
warning systems evacuation routes but
then you have my property because people
have slightly better infrastructure now
so what do I mean by doing you know a
gender and class analysis so what we saw
is that in each of these disasters again
higher proportion of women in terms of
mortality and morbidity rates higher
more girls and boys a lot of the women
stayed back to look after their goats
and cows and chickens they did not go
you know they didn't evacuate because
they didn't want their belongings their
meager belongings to be looted so there
was a real class and gender issues there
it's a very complex human tragedy story
someone go into that but then you also
have a gender issue in relief so here
from helicopters aid is being dropped
off to people but you see you know
people fighting and jostling and often
it's the men and not
early the women who often the
female-headed households a second issue
is even those infrastructure like these
cyclone evacuation shelters have been
built right it's supposed to be about 20
feet high so if you get a 20 feet high
storm surge but you know they're just
one big room so for all sorts of
patriarchal and cultural norms a lot of
women did not want to be packed in a
room with a bunch of men and there are
not separate toilet facilities so again
we see in good intentions gone awry
where a lot of women were not going to
the cyclone shelters because there were
incidences of harassment and rape and
people feeling uncomfortable so we see a
disaster and a tragedy just compounding
on itself so there's all sorts of
dynamics that go into the making of a
disaster right so cyclone is a hazard a
cyclone is a disaster where people are
involved and it's a gender disaster when
there's more women suffering at various
stages before during and after compared
to men that it makes it a more gender
disaster so the second case study
related to this but the first one
basically that I just showed you as well
with climate change willing to see
increasingly stronger cyclones and
higher storm surges so we're likely to
see other forms of human tragedies and
in the second case study which is again
from the Bay of Bengal but looking at
how are people responding to increasing
sea level now you can geologists can
argue with me about how much of this is
the actual mean sea level versus how
much of it is subsidence we can go into
that detail later but the important
thing is the sea level has been the mean
sea level has been rising there has been
a huge amount of salt water intrusion
into freshwater sources in the both the
shallow and the deep aquifers and into
their stories so what you're seeing is
people are responding by trying to make
a livelihood in a very harsh saline
water escape so this is a place of the
largest mangrove forests in the world
the Sun Durban mango force these are
trees that can survive in brackish water
which is here more and more of these
mangrove forests are being cut down out
there actually dying away too because of
too much salt Ryan not enough freshwater
and more and more of these are being cut
on and being turned into shrimp ponds
and this is where a class analysis
becomes important there's wealthier
people are flooding the rice paddy
fields or poorer farmers making them
cell line then the rice control and then
the poor farmer is kind of dispossessed
of Islam sells it off to the richer guy
who then grows shrimp because North
America and Western Europe loves shrimp
cocktails so lot of shrimp growth you
can say well that there you go you know
adaptive livelihood well not so much if
we do a gender analysis because who's
the cheap labor in these shrimp farms
it's women and girls will stand for
hours and waist deep neck deep water
catching the small shrimp Fra so there
we can part of that global industry of
underpaid devalued labor who then has to
carry some of the burdens of standing in
sea water all day so illnesses and and
all of that but not having a diversified
livelihood base right they can only work
for the shrimp firm or they have to
migrate into the cities and there are
also instances of harassment of women
you know and not enough freshwater so
again they had their walking further to
get fresh water for their families so
all kinds of things are coming to a head
in both their increasing sea-level rise
and then how people are responding to
that in terms of livelihood strategy so
while some folks may see this as a good
adaptation reality if you really do that
kind of micro level human analysis not
so much so I'm going to conclude are
basically kind of draw together all the
things that I've said and I know some of
those abstract but some of it hopefully
was humanized that when we think about
climate change we need to understand
that climate shields will impact social
relations and primarily through changes
in water both directly and indirectly
and in the two ways right too much water
too little water so water related
disasters and water scarcity or water
availability so what we need to do
basically is recognize this first first
of all is awareness and recognition and
then address the ways that water
unavailability and inequality in Mal
distribution can challenge fulfillment
of broader development go
rules and therefore we need to heat the
opportunities and the constraints that
exist because at the end of the day
water does everything right or it
doesn't do anything at all it doesn't
let you do what you want so in many ways
we're seeing climate change and the
effects it has on water base whether
through storms or lack thereof or like a
freshwater is bumping up against broader
Development Goals borrower societal
goals and it's definitely affecting
different groups of people in different
ways so a second point that I think is
really important is to recognize that
climate change and social implications
are not gender neutral I think I've
probably driven that nail on the coffin
a lot and hopefully all of you will go
out of here being really great feminist
scholars but recognize that social
analysis is and just say I did social
analysis I spoke to a person that
doesn't work and when we do that kind of
close gender or class or race analysis
it means we need to address the lack of
attention to class and gender data we
really need to have more disaggregated
data and pay attention to the issues or
highlight issues when they're not being
highlighted in both international and
national level or even regional level
climate change debates a third thing is
examined the multiplicity of environment
development issues in any given context
because the way water seeps through the
ground and in lakes and so on and so
forth there there's always going to be
host of water-related environment
development challenges whether it's crop
failure ecosystem dying out or what are
showing up where there was no water
before and people are responding to it
in different ways so we need to
therefore look at those much more human
and development and social progress
issues around unequal power relations
poverty and social marginalization that
interplay with climate change
disruptions and the so-called adaptation
projects right so it's doing social
analysis to processes that are
influenced by climate change what are
the projects that are being implemented
to address climate change and then what
the second part of this is really really
pay attention to the outcomes of
water-related chain
and again I think I've driven that pony
to the ground I think that's probably
the wrong way to say but what I mean is
pay attention to the really really
complex but very very important ways
that we're seeing increasing presence of
the complexities of water resource
management decisions play out in the
human world another issue is and this is
I think one of the hardest things to do
especially for planners and policymakers
is to look at the contextual linkages
between poverty social justice and
gender concerns in creating climate
resilient societies this is kind of
where most of the governments of the
developing world are at the trying to
figure out how do we do better
development that is more climate
resilient well if you aren't doing very
good development to begin with maybe
this is your opportunity to do it better
and then to pay attention to the things
you weren't paying attention to and if
you want to call that climate resilient
that's great but if it's more equitable
and you know pays attention to issues of
social justice I think all of us would
like our governments to do that right so
what this basically means is for whether
it's local planning people you know
small-scale large-scale regional scale
is playing careful attention to the
structural inequalities and power
relations in resource management not
just in society in some abstract way but
how do different groups of people manage
different resources you know across
sites and scales so do they have control
over something do they have user rights
due to have access rights are they part
of a more delivered deliberative and
participatory planning process so this
kind of comes back to development as a
whole and then we need to also integrate
very different perceptions and
experiences and abilities as I mentioned
earlier and then we need to also to
again not to just leave you with doom
and gloom but what are some positive
things that are happening people are
increasingly paying attention to
strengthening social networks to
alternative livelihood strategies and to
information sharing this is how we are
beginning the conversation and we are
beginning to see some change because at
the end of the day
we are you know one human society that
we have on this one planet earth and
there's always going to be some
inequities but we can try to do it
better right so this is my last slide
I'm going to conclude that in my opinion
well water is a human right and climate
disruptions will challenge fulfilling
basic rights of the poor globally so
whether we think about it as too much
water too little water we need to
contextualize it that at the end of the
day it is about having meaningful lives
but having a life with dignity and these
are just a couple of images about how
water maybe in the future right being
transported through armed guards and
you've got a picture that the mother
under an open top and that's just a
cover of the book that was mentioned
when I was being introduced looking at
the right to water it came out last year
thank you